[Music]
this year in cloud sequel we've really
focused on three large areas overall
performance and scale make all of our
databases faster make them scale more
easily make as much good as one such as
possible overall reliability and
availability because of your database
isn't available if it isn't reliable
what good is it
and then really full integration trying
to integrate it more deeply within GCP
itself and then also with the things out
in the ecosystems of my Segal and
Postgres that you care about and again
things like sequel server now as well
and we're proud of every single thing
we've done this year but I think a few
that really warrant discussion or things
like Postgres going GA 9.6 is GA and
again 11 is in beta our private IP work
and then our regional expansion which
we'll talk a little bit about as well so
lots and lots of stuff this year lots
and lots of stuff lots of new regions
one of the things people may have missed
is many many more flags we have for a
long time had a pretty restrictive
policy on what flags we allowed
administrators to set for the database
instances and ultimately we've kind of
decided that in many cases you know
bester you know what it is you're trying
to do and so if there was a flag in my
sequel or Postgres you were looking for
and you you couldn't find it check again
both in our documentation and in our
console UI you'll find most of the flags
that you're looking for for Postgres and
my sequel are now there we've upgraded
our proxy we've added push G is support
for JSON C my sequel external master has
been a really great way for
organizations to start to migrate their
my sequel workloads into a managed
system with cloud sequel rotating SSL
Certificates real real interesting move
on the security side and then
connections from cloud functions which I
think over time is going to grow into a
richer kind of external in trigger
system as well so again highlight
Postgres GA were seeing really really
great adoption in the Postgres side of
the offering I think those of you who
know about the growth of posters over
the last several years in the community
understand that for certain enterprise
functions it really is becoming the open
source database of choice it's part of
the reason we're going to have Simon
join us to talk through some of the
things
you know as we move into 11 but with
Postgres going GA that means we now have
SLA coverage and it's gonna be a major
focus for us in the year to come as well
high availability again if your database
isn't there it's not really worth it
until high availabilities been a big
focus for us on both the Postgres and my
sequel sides of the house and it's worth
breaking these out a little bit because
we're doing them a little bit
differently now on the my sequel side of
the house
you can add high availability with just
a single click and what you're getting
is bin log replications you're getting
semi synchronous replication and we're
monitoring replication lag as our
failover signal now that means that
there's no app level difference for
highly available stuff it's the same as
a single interface but you do have the
option to use in that secondary replica
is a little bit of a read replica as
well but you're dealing with the notion
of replication lag as well we're doing
things a little bit differently on the
Postgres side and and this is actually
gonna be the strategy more broadly going
forward for our high availability for
sequel server for Postgres and maybe
we'll eventually bring it back to the my
sequel world as well which is actually
to build on replicated persistent disks
now this is a truly synchronous
replication and so we're actually
replicating the block device underneath
the instance and to be honest this is
something we're really only able to do
because of Google's overall network
capacity it's very very demanding to
replicate a whole block device
synchronously now what this means though
is that there's no replication lag and
it changes our fail of our metric a
little bit so in this case if we get 60
seconds with no heartbeat we know we
need to failover now you can't use that
instance as a rege replica but you can
set up regular read replicas to use
otherwise and you can continue to serve
data from those from a healthy zone even
if that primary has gone down and we're
in the process of failing over and then
private IP I think is actually a big
deal for the security contrast and for
those who are latency sensitive as well
private IP is now available throughout
the cloud sequel line and this is gonna
allow you to peer your VPC with the
Google V PC in which our instance lives
now what does that mean for you
well that means lower latency for one
also means that all traffic is encrypted
you can apply TLS to that as well if you
want to but it's gonna be encrypted and
never exposed to the public Internet and
and that is going to be a major driver
for certain organizations that are
network security sensitive wrong green
button and then regional expansion I
think this has been a highlight for GCP
the last three years running now is just
how rapidly we're trying to expand
across the globe and we're now in 58
zones I'm not sure exactly how many
regions that is it's many regions each
with at least three zones and this is
really giving you the opportunity to
locate your databases closest to where
you need to run your application closest
to where you need to do business and
again this allows us the ability to have
our replication exist in any one of the
regions with again good failure domains
across the zones and now let's get on to
the next part of our discussion where
we're gonna dig more into the meat of
some of the offerings themselves we're
gonna talk about Postgres sequel 11 and
a lot of things you should know if
you've only been running 9 6 or maybe
running 10 there are a lot of
improvements in 11 that are really
interesting to talk about and we're
really really lucky to have Simon Riggs
with us I mean if you want to come up
Simon is the founder and CEO second
quadrant send Cointreau provides a wide
variety of Postgres services in over
what 20 countries is that right and and
collectively they have over 200 personal
years of Postgres experience now
importantly Simon is not just the CEO of
second quadrant he's also an active
developer and committer and Postgres and
he's helped bring things like P ITR to
the community and and partitioning
replication so we're gonna get the
opportunity not only to see Postgres
work in the field and talk about that
but also then sort of the committers
perspective on where the database is
going so please welcome sign
[Applause]
Simon thank you for coming this is gonna
be a little awkward so all right so
let's let's start to talk first about
parallelism so I think one of the things
I noticed in 11 is there's been a lot of
enhancements to parallelism you know we
see it in parallel query we see it in
parallel index build so one thing I
wonder about is given that scan types
and join types are now increasingly
parallel what are some things that users
should know when they think about how
parallelism is would apply in their
database okay well I think in 96 we
introduced the basics of parallelism but
we didn't really roll that out to
everything that could be parallelized
whereas by the time we get to postcodes
eleven of the journeys almost done
if you look at what we've done in
postcodes 12 release cycle mostly bug
fixing and I'm actually very happy that
we got the main join types done in post
close 10 and 11 so for example initially
we did hash joins but they didn't use a
single hash table though they had a
separate table per yeah which was very
wasteful so you know so we really were
at the stage of hitting the secondary
and tertiary issues with parallelism so
it's almost done really very happy with
it so if users haven't really thought
about how parallelism how to take
advantage of parallel query or the
things that they should think about in
terms of setting up their schema the way
they think about you know table
architecture that will help increase
their ability to leverage parallelism
yes I mean it's possible to get large
parallel databases the you know existing
out there with different databases but
with postgrads what we focused on is
small parallelism so intra node
parallelism so we really were looking
for queries that can be somewhere
between two and four times faster using
this intra node
so really a lot of important areas occur
in applications whether we've got
certain queries that are a bit slower
than they should be
but they're not running for necessarily
hours they could be like things that run
for say a minute and we if we can get
that down to ten seconds or two seconds
then its goal achieved so you know we're
not really talking about the same world
encompassing parallelism that you get
from some other products but making
simple changes to the response time of
of real-world queries it seems that that
you know we would look to see that maybe
in operational workloads that are
dependent on real low latency or
operational reporting and things like
that yes I think what we're saying with
postcodes is that the old idea of an
OLTP system where all the transactions
are short isn't really what what we see
now there's a whole mixed workload where
you get OLTP but also complex analytical
queries happening immediately
for example asking the question where's
your nearest coffee shop or you know
what's the best hotel for this
particular customer to staying there
they they need to be quick but they're
not short in terms of the analytical
power required to answer them and those
are the things that we're targeting now
I suppose as the modern OLTP database
becomes more analytically oriented right
this this actually matters this notion
of going from a minute to 10 seconds can
be huge so so another thing that's
interesting is parallelism in index
builds and I know people in the my
sequel world would be familiar with
things like parallel apply can you say a
little bit about how parallelism for
background work is evolving in Postgres
so in terms of things maintenance
functions I mean we've got parallel
vacuum we've got parallel index build
which the main ones really we have moved
away from the idea of trying to do
maintenance on
X's so just rebuilding the index is a
practical task and because we can do
that concurrently is fairly simple to
build a new index rather than try to
maintain the other one there aren't a
whole load of other operations that
you'd need to do in the background but
one thing we have done is parallelized
create table as select which is quite
important for building summary tables
and and such like which is an important
application technique so that's that's
really one of the key things I think was
the skeeters Yesi test improvement is
actually really huge I mean you're
talking about any kind of summary either
pre offload to a warehouse or for
operational reporting like that that can
have a huge impact so let's talk a
little bit about partitioning so I look
at 11 and I think this is the
partitioning released in a lot of ways
and and you you were very early in
partitioning but one of the things that
that people may not know about 11 versus
previous versions is that we're no
longer strictly in sort of table
inheritance mode we've got table
attribute partitioning it's native but
if you're coming from Postgres and
you've thought about oh well you know I
read Stack Overflow and I saw these
inherited tables it's different now and
and so what should what should
implementers think about either if
they're as they're moving from nine six
upwards or ten upwards or if they're
designing a schema from scratch and
trying to think about how do I take the
best advantage of the variety of
partitioning options so yeah I mean I
was originally involved in the work on
partitioning back ten years ago and
frankly if I don't not to dis myself but
the work that we did there was crude and
it led to some shortcomings really with
the types of application that we could
support so what we've done now is
completely redesigned that implement it
from scratch the way it should be done
and as a result we're able to support
things like unique indexes on partition
tables and foreign keys are obviously
very key for for applications and and
it's really made a big difference to the
way that people are able to use this now
so partitioning isn't even done yet
really in 11 we've still got a lot of
good performance features coming in
twelve
and in 13 so partitioning is a really
big application area for post grazing
maybe other databases as well but we you
know we see those requirements coming
very strongly from from a whole range of
users because there's just so much data
these days that people want to log and
partitioning really makes that effective
so I guess just to poke on that a little
bit given given you know the wide
variety of things that are now present
in partitioning do you think that opens
the door for organisations or users who
are looking to move off of other our
DBMS that have had maybe expensive
partitioning packages or something like
that um yeah I mean do you think that
the level of functionality is enough
that like there's a whole new wave of
workloads that can come to Postgres with
with Elevens partitioning yes I mean the
the style of feature development with
both Grose's because we're releasing
features annually we will release a
feature and then add things to our over
the next couple of years so it's not you
know maybe five or ten years ago you'd
wait five years for the next release and
then it would all come in one rush
except they would still be stuff broken
right and then you'd wait another five
years for it to be fixed so the
postcodes ways to release stuff a lot
earlier what we have with the initial
partitioning is select queries will be
fully optimized inserts or optimized
into it it's not really until post
queries 11 that updates and deletes are
beginning to be optimized and we've done
more work on that in 12 as well so the
the range of workloads is evolving so if
you want to do insert only sort of
append only workloads they work just
fine in post goes 11 but we'll be moving
on to a whole range of other
applications your your slides their
mention partition wise joins and
partition movement those two features
are particularly relevant for sharding
style applications built using
partitioning whether the partitions
actually exist on Sep
nodes and that's really a direction that
we're moving in for the next couple of
releases is is that sharding concept so
not too long away from having a fully
slotted database running on Postgres so
that's great I guess you make an
interesting point there around the
Postgres release cadence and and I think
we're people who are thinking about
planning potential migrations to post
grass if partitioning is a strong
requirement this notion that well we can
begin to plan our migration now as the
features are set but improving it maybe
can actually reduce some of the risk
profile of that kind of a migration
definitely I think what some people say
is that they won't move to a release
until it's been out for six months well
obviously with postcodes coming out
annually you don't really have to wait
as long as you did before quite frankly
the profile of testing has changed
dramatically in software generally and
most specifically in post grows so
whereas we used to rely on the kind of
many eyeballs effect for people
reporting queries the extent of our test
automation is now I mean I can't put a
number on it but it's it's much
different to to how it was and so you
you have a lot of trust in the dot zero
release now whereas before people said
well maybe wait for the dot one dot two
but you know it's usable really from the
word go so every September now you
should be thinking about upgrading your
both screws that's really interesting so
let's talk about another one of these
hey maybe I haven't expensive database
at home and I'm interested in getting
away from it um another huge thing in in
eleven is stored procedures and you know
I think the communities had functions
for a long time but procedures they play
a real role in ensuring conformance in
reducing network traffic a bunch of
things um and you guys did sync a Quadra
it actually did a lot of work on the
stored procedures as well can you talk a
little bit about you know what you think
they mean for the community and I guess
same question
you know if I'm thinking about coming
from a database that that
is on premises or is is you know maybe
something I'm trying to get off of but
store procedures have been a blocker how
is the door open now in a way that it
wasn't okay so the big I mean there's a
small difference between procedures and
functions I mean functions are is
essentially or procedures are you know I
mean they're very similar in many ways
but the key difference that we've
introduced with stored procedures is the
ability to run transactions inside the
procedure and that is a really pivotal
difference it's important for migration
from other databases but it allows you
to do a whole range of things you really
weren't able to do before
so batch style query processing and
we're also sort of moving towards
autonomous transactions within
procedures perhaps in the next release
but the style of programming changes
completely because when you add a
function that would only exist within
one transaction you're now having a
procedure that can exist perhaps
generating thousands of transactions as
it executes completely different style
of programming and it really moves a lot
of the business logic through to the
server now because whereas before you
had to ask for one transaction and then
another transaction the procedure can
just do it all it's like come back when
you're finished now and that means that
the network traffic that you're reducing
between the application and the database
is really considerable now so we get the
full benefit of offloading things to the
database obviously not every single
piece of your application should live in
the database okay I think some people
tried to persuade people that was a good
idea and it's not okay but there are
some things that make sense to be close
to the data okay and for those it's
ideal it's interesting that you
mentioned the notion of having multiple
transactions within the procedure you
know I recall you know working in
financial services in other places that
notion of straight through processing
can be a real impediment for for certain
organizations that need to make sure
that when this Row is touched all of
these other rows are updated
and so this really opens the door to
that does that you do find that your
your scene growth in the sort of
regulated industries on Postgres yeah I
mean probably half of our customer bases
financial services now very widely used
across financial industries and when I
say that I think some people think
alright
so somewhere in the back room he's got
like one most gross database and he's
claiming that as usage right now I'm
talking about card processing is now
frontline done on Postgres so if you buy
something on various cloud providers you
will find that that goes through
postcodes databases and there's
literally hundreds of billions of
dollars annually processed directly on
postcodes databases supported by us by
the way well there's there's something
interesting within that too and you
start to talk about global organizations
I know one of the areas that that's you
know the second quadrants done a lot of
work beyond things like stored
procedures is also a logical replication
things like BDR you know could you talk
for a moment about how you're seeing you
know sort of cross regional replication
emerging in the Postgres community and
the kinds of use cases you're seeing for
it be a disaster recovery or you know
split transaction processing the sorts
of things that really show up there yeah
I think you know there's various ways of
doing high availability within a single
region but when you go cross region
things become a lot more complex and
some of the storage replication
techniques that that are possible become
much more problematic so post-crisis
invested a lot of time in second
quadrant as well in what we call logical
replication and the purpose of that is
to filter out all of the physical
replication stuff so that we're just
down to the basic data so that reduces
bandwidth but it also allows you to do
things like upgrade between release and
it certainly makes
cross region replication significantly
easier and something with something like
BDR we actually have global geo sharding
where you can actually have pools of
data in different continents and you're
all working together
so again important technologies
especially in regulated industries and
just in case folks don't know what BD r
is bi-directional replication that's I
think you and I know enough there's of
course this so let's talk about we
talked a little bit about the importance
of analytics within the Postgres world
and I mean in a lot of ways post course
is really well positioned to be both
your analytical workhorse and for
operational things and your old T P
database the other thing that really
stood out to me in in eleven is the
changes to analytical sequel and and you
know I think in many ways I look at
post-crisis sequels in Texas being in a
lot of cases at the very edge of how we
think about the sequel language so for
folks who haven't looked at it
Postgres 11 gives us frame exclusions
which i think are really really powerful
ways to actually remove things from the
windowing frame and then also group
frame units which is which is I don't
think any other database today does
group frame window eight can you can you
talk a little bit about you know each of
these in like what it what it means to
the analytical workload sure so I think
what a lot of people don't realize with
SQL is that it's had window functions in
it for some time now what a window
function is is it allows you to look at
data in an order to manner and this is
especially important for time series
where you if you look if you're thinking
about your data as a graph where the
points change over time then if you can
write queries that analyze that data so
that you have a sliding frame of data so
for example if you look at the current
row of data you can look at the last
five preceding rows and write something
like a a moving average which is
obviously a very important analytical
calculation so this has actually been in
the sequel standard
many years and postcodes has had support
in that for coming up for ten years now
but in the latest release we've got
these fine fine grained extensions
really that the put the finishing
touches to post grosses support and the
ones that you mentioned there really are
just important in really just getting
the the last few dregs of information
out of that style of query and what's
really surprising though is is we we're
finishing the implementation of these
features and yet many people have never
even heard of them okay and so you know
sometimes when we talk about SQL as a
kind of boring language that existed
from 30 years ago people are not really
you know moving with the fact that that
it's actually evolved very considerably
over time
yeah modern modern sequel is really
something because yet to think a little
bit about that to the finer grains at a
frame exclusion I might have my moving
average but I might want to say well
give me the last five values but remove
the duplicates right and and that could
actually have a really material change
on the average I'm computing and again
that sliding window doesn't know it
necessarily have to be rows preceding
anymore right it can now be groups and
so if I'm actually talking about group
by averages that can be really
interesting all right so let's let's
talk a little bit about data types
I think Postgres already has got a
really rich support for data types
whether it be array types structure
types domains but I think one area
that's interesting is semi structured
data because JSON and JSON B have become
I think you know interesting additions
to to Postgres in general and in
particular I think at 11 we got full
text indexing or which might have been
10 I'm not a hundred percent certain so
are you seeing more use of semi
structured data in the Postgres world
now that these features are available
very much so I think people have bought
into the concepts of semi structured
data from a lot of other databases but
they want to use those concepts within a
normal database structure so they want
to be able to mix the concepts together
there are you know relational works
but up to a point and then when once you
go sort of past that point where you hit
the complexity wall semi-structured data
is really useful so it's it's great to
be able to just have a column where you
have sort of data blobs in and you know
Jason and Jason B's just excellent for
that so we have lots of people using it
so it's it's not something that's in you
know in the backgrounds it's really one
of our key features these days the the
Jason B data type compresses the data so
we store it compressed but in a way that
you can still search on the compressed
data which obviously is a very important
feature so the the full text support
that we've released in Postgres 11 is
actually enabling two things that the
were in post grows previously obviously
the Jason data type but the full text
support
allowed us to build indexes on data but
in a very complex way so we could have
things like a Russian grammar for words
in the JSON blobs and you've got things
like a stemmer that will take the front
portion of the word so instead of you
know word that ends with eng we can just
take off thing and it'll be the the main
word that we're talking about now and we
can just index that instead so that the
full support of full text is now
available on top of Jason B data so a
very important combination that's really
interesting I think one of the things
that that's kind of highlights between
thinking about the analytic functions
thinking about you know semi structured
data types and being able to actually
effectively do complex processing on
them is that you know you know I often
think of post cursors oh it's an old TP
system mostly but the reality of it is
is it's really a multi multi model
database in a lot of ways like if you
need to do things that are somewhat key
value oriented if you need to do things
that are more sort of you know
elasticsearch full-text indexing and
like these are all capabilities
available to you and if you need to
bring them all together
one database close Christ is really
about the best you can do in the open
source world very much I mean I think
that's really been the power of
post-crisis too while many vendors have
been highlighting I've got this great
database as long as you accept this long
list of restrictions okay
and then you know and then there's
another database server that has a
different long list of restrictions and
trying to build an application that
integrates different servers together
you know works at the prototype stage
and then someone says how will I back it
up and simple things like that become
really complex and what postcodes has
done is said really there aren't any
restrictions you can have all manner of
data types with all manner of index
types and we support OLTP queries longer
analytical queries we support graph
queries for example not very well known
window queries and this really gives you
a breadth to post grows that means that
when you're building an application you
can be pretty certain that you will be
able to build it on post cose where some
of the other platforms you have to look
carefully at the list of restrictions
before you decide whether to use it or
not and if your restrictions change
after your initial build you're in
problems and that's really the strength
of postcodes has been the confidence
that it gives application builders
because as I said you can be certain
that postcards will run it yeah it's
actually a great platform to avoid free
optimization right you can you can
optimize when you need to but if you're
not quite sure post Chris we'll probably
at least get you most of the way all
right so it's a new release and you
can't have a new release of a database
without somebody want to talk about
speeds and feeds so this is this is not
any kind of an official benchmark this
is just I spent a little bit of time one
afternoon looking at Post Chris 9:6 on
cloud sequel and Postgres 11 on cloud
sequel I was just looking to sort of
effectively TPM see and you know I think
we I see some interesting things right
the the
reticle throughput is is up overall we
see improved behaviors but I know
there's been a bunch of work that's gone
into the planner into stats collection
things like that anything you want to
say broadly about overall performance in
11 or things that usually should be
aware of they should be taking advantage
of that maybe you know they didn't read
deeply enough in the liner notes to know
about well thank you for asking that
question because that's really that
though things I like to highlight is
those things that are kind of buried in
the notes but really I'd like to
celebrate what you see on the screen
there because if you look I mean that
the numbers there are extraordinary
we've gone from 8,000 TPM to 12 and a
half thousand which is more than a 50%
gain in performance in OLTP and that's
really just one workload that has been
optimized because there's a there's a
whole range of other workloads that we
support so I mean that in itself is you
know we could talk for five minutes
really about that but really to answer
your your wider question what we've been
doing is not just expanding the
execution speed of queries with things
like aggregation improvements or
parallel query but we also looked at the
statistical information that we keep
within the database so we now support
something called the create statistics
command and what that allows you to do
is tell the database that multiple
columns are actually linked for example
there's a common example of in the u.s.
you have area code and state now we all
know the area code and state are related
but the optimizer doesn't and it's only
when you tell it that these two columns
are actually related and you know the
area code for Los Angeles is not the
Eric you know is not possible to have a
customer with an area code in Los
Angeles when they live in New Jersey it
just doesn't happen
okay and so the optimizer can use those
types of information to really change
the selectivity estimates and when you
get their selectivity estimates right
you get the right query plan and most of
the reason for poor performing queries
is actually because of the the
optimizers ability to understand what's
happening so I don't want to denigrate
the the massive work done on parallel
query at all but we've done an equal
amount of work on the optimizer on
statistics so for example in Post grows
10 we introduced for the first time
foreign keys into planning so previously
foreign key foreign keys were just a
constraint right whereas now the foreign
keys are actually taken into account in
the planning and that means you get much
better plans and faster queries as a
result so those are not really admin
tasks there's some pretty cool admin
things out there as well but really
performance across the across all of the
different workloads has improved really
quite considerably that's awesome and
yeah I think that the notion of of
understanding that we can now actually
help improve those plans in ways we
couldn't before like yeah any of us who
any of us who've ever run a benchmark
know that you don't get a good plan I
think that's just like life it's just
like life all right well Simon thank you
so so much for joining us everybody give
it up for Simon Riggs CEO of second
quadrant
Wow there's a lot of stuff in PG eleven
you guys have got to go check out it's
it's really really cool
so let's talk just briefly about the
year ahead and and then I'll hand it
back over to Orie who's gonna give us
another taste of sequel server in case
you didn't see it on the keynote stage
so in 2019 there's a lot of stuff we're
interested in new database versions new
databases for example some security
features we think are really important
customer managing encryption keys this
is a broad requirement for all of Google
cloud and you're gonna see it in cloud
sequel very very soon richer auditing
Simon and I talked a little bit about
regulated industry financial services
healthcare we really want to improve the
level of audit ability in cloud sequel
so that we're yet again further ready
for these kinds of workloads we're also
gonna spend a lot of time this year
focusing on manageability if you've run
cloud sequel and you wonder about
maintenance events we know we know we're
working on both deferrals and event
controls and these are things we're
really going to focus on on making at
least first-class in in the coming year
point in time recovery for all of our
databases is a huge priority we already
have it in the my sequel world you'll
see it in Postgres and obviously you'll
see it in sequel server since that's
something you expect our overall
manageability UI we're gonna invest a
lot of time into and try and improve
that and we're also going to start to
begin a journey towards greater
Federation with the rest of the GCP
platform one of the areas that we expect
to invest in this year's Federation from
bigquery which is to say if you have a
warehouse stored in Google bigquery
you'll be able to reach in to your
Postgres database and query analytical
data or query operational data that may
live there we're also very interested in
potentially having post gross reach out
to the rest of GCP we think that's a
really interesting area that we're gonna
investigate going forward and with that
I'm gonna go ahead and turn it over to
Ori who's gonna tell us about sequel
server hey thank you very much
hi everyone so I am here today to talk
to you about product you I'm sure I've
never heard of sequel server we're
really excited to announce that we've
expanded our portfolio for cloud sequel
and now
we'll be offering men a sequel server
currently we're launching our closed
alpha beta will come towards the end of
this year and that will be open to all
customers now a lot of what Dan was
talking about and why it's so important
to be part of the cloud sequel family is
really that sequel server is going to
take advantage of a lot of the platform
goodness that we're bringing already to
my sequel and Postgres over the coming
year and leverage that same you know the
same set of features so when you talk
about you know I get the question all
the time you know what regions is sequel
so we're gonna be available and the
answer is everywhere that cloud sequel
is available that's where sequel server
is available and same goes for what are
you know automated backup story is going
to be a point in time recovery is coming
patching story all that you know we are
going to have kind of this unified
experience that you can come to expect
as a standard from GCP for our managed
services and sequel server will be no
exception and so that's going to add all
you know hopefully a lot of value reduce
a lot of the overhead in terms of
managing sequel server and how it
interacts with your apps additionally I
want to talk a little bit about
compatibility so you know sequel server
in most organizations that we've run
through with a lot of the customers they
already have kind of their their
workflows baked in you know they have
their favorite tools they have their
third-party you know analytic services
or whatever else they're kind of running
on top of sequel server one of our top
goals is actually to make sure that you
know we are able to preserve that level
of compatibility so you know we're not
going to introduce something where you
have to break your normal flow you know
retrain a bunch of your folks you know
we expect you to be able to continue
doing business as usual and just with a
managed service in the background to
reduce again a lot of that maintenance
and overhead just some quick bullets so
you know sequel server 2017 is gonna be
the version that we're going out with as
I said there is kind of this versioning
strategy across across all of our manage
database services that we will continue
to keep up-to-date with of course the
minor revisions and as the major
versions come out to we'll evaluate them
and make them available as well we're
starting out with our alpha standard
but we will at the time of bid nga have
all editions available to our customers
the VM shapes that are underlying this
are gonna be the same as the rest of
cloud sequel again you know there's that
kind of standardization across the cloud
sequel family and so everything that you
you see that customized I think already
in Postgres there's custom VM shapes you
know that's actually the standard that
we're gonna adopt the only limitation of
course is going to be the different
editions of sequel server have kind of
baked in limits on what they can utilize
as far as memory in cores and things
like that and then you know finally
again I Dan touched on this a little bit
you know with a comment about Federation
with bigquery but you know I think it it
bears repeating that you know
integration with stock driver
integration with all the other available
tools and services that kind of
proliferate around the GCP ecosystem is
going to be one of the biggest value
adds that we have in sequel server is
going to benefit a lot from from that
and so if you are already kind of a
customer for any of our other services
using compute using something else you
know this should be an easy add-on to if
you have you know a stubborn workload
that's remained on Prem or in a VM even
in GCE that you want to kind of go to a
managed model that's something that will
be available to you
I think the slides are available after
the session so there is a link if you
are interested in alpha to show your
interest signup you know we have a set
of customers selected now but we'll be
expanding the alpha as we get closer to
beta and we welcome any interested
parties you know we're happy to have you
if if their space with that's everyone's
favorite thing a demo so this is
actually running on sequel Server 2008
r2
it's going end of life obviously in a
you know later on this year and if just
a few short months actually team that we
start out with dot back as the first
supported you know back camera store
file type obviously that's the the
native one for for sequel server I know
the team worked very hard to make sure
that that is first out the gate and then
after that we actually have an
incredibly simple import flow and it's
very similar to what you've already seen
for the sequel and dot CSV imports but
I'm just going to go and select this dot
pack file that I've uploaded previously
there we go I just named it - let's call
this one I'll click import and while
that is happening I'll actually just
usually don't only takes a minute I'll
copy over the IP I've got the
configuration file over here I'll paste
it any luck it should still be up yep
all set so now this web app is running
on our managed service and we've it was
that simple and that's actually our goal
for our customers so you know we want to
make sure that you know if you have more
complex apps obviously it's gonna be
more than the suffice for us I just
showed you but we we want to provide you
with the tooling not just the simple
flows but also through third-party
relationships through through other tool
sets that will make available you of
course heard about the Illuma
acquisition that happened earlier this
year or just earlier this month and
we're really doubling down on making
sure that the migration onto GCP onto
our managed services is smooth and
painless one other thing I wanted to
call out before the we get to the Q&A is
actually two things one is a quick shout
out to our managed to ad service that is
also launching right now and for GCE as
a whole we kind of have an entire
windows ecosystem offering now which
it's a much more complete story than you
know what was of course previously
available and so you know whether you're
trying to run Windows Server on you know
on GCE
whether you're looking to use our
managed ad service and manage tickle
server you know now you don't have to
kind of bitwise or piecemeal move on to
the platform you know we can actually
accommodate your entire ecosystem in
your entire stack
[Music]